welcome to the heavy spoilers show I'm
your host definition and with the Joker
being shown at film festivals worldwide
it was only a matter of time before
leaks from the movie made their way to
the Internet
whilst we can't show the clips in this
video due to Warner Brothers striking
channels and bringing them down I will
be discussing everything that happens in
them just in case you didn't get a
chance to watch them before they got
removed there are some huge huge
spoilers for the movie here so if you
don't want to go into the film with some
of the big pot elements ruined that I
highly recommend that you turn off now
without the way I just want to give a
huge thank you for clicking the video
now let's get into the breakdown of the
footage ok so the first clip shows the
Joker dancing on the steps in public in
his full costume he's strutting about to
rock and roll part 2 by Gary Glitter
which yeah I don't know why they given
that guy money but he's thumping away on
the stairs and seems to be having a
blast with it
Joaquin Phoenix is fully inhabiting the
role and it's full of slow-mo shots and
seems like a music video at some points
that really sets the tone for the film
the next leak was a two-minute clip of
the Joker on the show with Marie
Franklin played by Robert De Niro and
Joker says knock-knock
Murray says who's there and Joker says
it's the police your son's been killed
by a drunk driver
rich yeah I was trying I'll try I wasn't
laughing at that I promise a promise on
that one the old heads and myself
included gasp and condemn him for not
being funny and then Joker apologizes
but says it's been a rough week ever
since he killed those three Wall Street
people the audience gasped again and
Murray says he's waiting for the
punchline but Joker says it's not a joke
we didn't get the Marc Maron cameo and
Murray asks if he killed the people on
the subway which to me confirms that the
plot leaks that we got were true as this
was a big point in them Joker tries to
justify the killing and says that he
finds their death funny and that comedy
is subjective and that he's sick of
people deciding what's right and what's
wrong and he then says he killed them
because they were awful and that
everyone is awful these days and it's
time to make a change Murray says that
not everyone is awful and to stop
wallowing in self-pity office says
Murray is awful because he only invited
him on the
so to make fun of him and Mary tries to
get him taken off which is when Joker
says I've got another joke what do you
get when you take a mentally ill person
and invite them on the show to make fun
of them he then shockingly shoots Murray
in the head which splatters blood
everywhere and yet just completely
catches you off God
Joker gets up in the studio and begins
killing people mercilessly it's really
extreme and it's also a gripping scene
that even in these short segments had me
on edge and I was almost kind of
panicked at just how much things had
escalated the next one shows Joker being
chased by police on the train and
authorities start closing on him
the train is packed full of clowns and
after starting a fight Joker takes a
mask off of one of them and is able to
blend in with the rest we shown a lot in
the trailers and seems like a smart way
to operate to get around the law the
final clip is probably the most shocking
one and has Joker in white facepaint but
without the red lips and eyes and he's
with what I think is his father now in
the leaks we did hear that he abused him
as a child and Arthur was brought up
believing that his father was Thomas
Wayne and this robiola he wasn't and was
in fact his abusers son really broke him
we see this in the scene as Joker
violently stabs him in the neck before
smashing his head against a wall in the
house completely showering his skull he
keeps battering it and honestly it just
gets so extreme like I was pretty
shocked that is how hard they went with
it
Arthur's father's accomplice cowers in
the corner crying asking why he did it
and Joker says it's crazy that he's on
telly tonight he says the accomplice can
leave Bert he's a dwarf and can't reach
the door to get out which is when the
scene ends now from these you can
definitely see why this is a hard R it
is probably the best-looking DC film
I've ever seen cinematography wise and
it's so visceral and raw that it's hard
not to just be sat on the edge you be
see through it this is brutal and it
reminds me a lot of Logan especially the
hardest part of that movie as it's just
non-stop when it ramps up I think the
film has an incredible tone to it and
you can see why it's getting so much
praise of these short clips alone this
has the potential to be the best comic
book movie ever made
and I'm just so glad that DC are going
in a new direction and not trying to
copy Marvel because this just looks
incredible
obviously I'd love to hear your thoughts
on the clips and if you managed to see
the leaks before they were taken down
make sure you leave your thoughts on
them in the comment section below if you
enjoyed this video then please like it
and make sure you check out my full
leaked pop breakdown of the movie which
will be linked at the end these leaks
pretty much confirm all of it for me so
definitely watch that if you want to
know more if you want to come talk to me
about movies TV shows games and comic
books and you can follow me on twitter
at definition YT it's the best way to
get in touch with me and it's the
perfect place to suggest new videos and
content so hopefully I see you over
there after this also just wanna let you
know that we're giving away a free copy
of spider-man far from home on blu-ray
and all you have to do to be in with a
chance of winning is to like this video
make sure that you subscribe to the
channel and leave your thoughts on the
Joker leaks in the comments section
below the winner will be chosen at
random on October the 15th and the
blu-ray will be shipped out from then to
have a good surprise it's the best of
luck to everyone who takes part this is
a channel for people who are super into
superheroes so if that's the kind of
thing you like hit subscribe thanks
again for taking the time to watch this
I've been definition you've been the
best and I'll see you next time take
care peace
[Music]
[Music]
you
[Music]
[Music]